[Music]
[Music]
over the last few days i've been playing
through the new rainbow six extraction
i'll be the first to admit that leading
up to this point i wasn't overly excited
by what i'd seen
but after around 20 hours of game time
i'm struggling to put it down
in this video i'll be running through
some of the mechanics and activities and
give some of my thoughts around what it
does well and what could be improved on
rainbow six extraction doesn't have a
campaign as such it's more of a
progression system where you would jump
in run one to three objective based
missions and extract
if successful you earn experience and
gear and start unlocking new map
locations and more challenging content
and modes
there is no linear mission line to
follow
once unlocked there is four locations
within each of these there are three
sectors you can pick from
you will then be shown a group of three
random objectives for each sub-zone of
the operation
once you've chosen your operator you and
your team are dropped into the first
subzone
if you're anything like me and you've
been playing too many run and gun
shooters for a while you'll find this a
little challenging to start with on my
very first mission i ran solo guns are
blazing and i think i was dead in about
three minutes
the objectives vary quite considerably
and for maximum success each of these
should be tackled in different ways
the majority of the time stealth is your
friend though for some of the more
challenging objectives it's a given that
you'll end up an open gunfight
eventually
however there are some we may not need
to fire your weapon at all
the maps are much larger than i was
expecting probably two to three times
the size of a typical siege map
the enemies are crazy
my first encounter with them when
playing solo late at night they scare
the crap out of me
they're fast loud and you can hear their
creepy noises when you start getting
close
there are more than 10 different types
of enemy to kill each with their own
abilities and behaviors these range from
your typical zombie-like grunts to the
behemoth smashes
there are also a number of different
alien things dotted around certain maps
like spores sludge squishy blobby things
that drop down from the ceiling and
attach to you but there is also a chance
for certain mutations to appear this
could lead to some enemies gaining a
cloaking ability or having a hardened
shell plus a number of others so i
haven't come across yet
each enemy has a weak spot or a best way
of taking it down so you have to be
careful with how you approach each fight
again coordination is key
sometimes you'll even need someone to be
the bait
while it's possible to solo play it is
considerably more difficult
with a bit of practice and a lot of
mucking around with my operator loadouts
i'm now able to complete a set of three
objectives on my own but i think the
scaling for solo play could be tweaked a
bit
as i said it's still completely possible
just more challenging with certain
objectives and much slower
i'm traditionally more of a solo player
but i personally found it a more
enjoyable tactical experience with a
team
especially when you start synchronizing
your operators and strategies
there is matchmaking but given the
coordination required i can see that
being a little bit hit and miss
depending on who you end up being
matched with
the operators have been taken directly
from rainbow six siege they've been
somewhat tweaked to match the different
style of gameplay but still feel very
much the same
one of the things i like most is the
fact that the operator damage and deaths
carry over
i don't just mean while progressing
through the different types of
objectives while on mission but after
each mission is finished as well
it makes it properly feel like you're
running with a roster
if you have a favorite operator you
can't just keep using it over and over
even on the best runs you're likely to
take a bit of damage
yes you can be healed by various things
while on missions but this is just
temporary
in order to bring your operator back to
full health you need to let them rest
while using other operators the
experience they gained has a direct
effect on how much health they will
receive the more experience gained the
more health that is given to your
injured operators
again this is just another area where
solo player is a little bit tougher you
generally take a little more damage and
experience takes a little longer to gain
it is possible to use an operator who
isn't at full health but depending on
how much damage you'd be making things
hard for yourself
however there is a limit if too injured
you'll need to wait until they've healed
a bit before you can use them again if
your operator is fully downed while out
on a mission and one of your teammates
was unable to carry you back and extract
your operator becomes mia
before you are able to heal and use this
operator again it needs to be
rescued all in all i quite like this
feature as it has you thinking a bit
more around which operator to use and it
also further adds to the tactical nature
of how you choose to play the missions
as taking some massive damage can
essentially remove the operator from the
roster while it heals
there are two things you are levelling
your operators and your personal
milestone
as you'd expect you level up your
operators by using them on missions
all experience gained will go through to
your milestone level as well
gaining experience with your operators
will open up new weapons and gear as
well as increasing certain base stats
like armor and speed
this will also unlock upgrades to the
gadget in some cases making them
considerably more effective
milestone levels will unlock more
operators and mission locations as well
as the in-game content
on top of this more gear and tech will
become available over time allowing more
options for your operator loadouts
another way to gain a bit of experience
is through the challenges
each location has a list of challenges
to complete they get progressively more
difficult
these will reward you with experience a
piece of the law and the occasional
cosmetic item
the story direction of extraction is a
little weird for a tom clancy game
but after the outbreak event the
community pushed for them to make a mode
or game based on this so we can hardly
complain about them listening to the
player base
but it would be nice if they'd taken the
story in a different direction
say if the aliens were replaced with a
terrorist organization or something but
it is what it is
one thing i really must note is that the
build felt very clean i didn't have any
technical issues at all this is a very
positive sign though we'll see how the
servers handled the increased load after
release
unfortunately i didn't give far enough
by the time of writing this to try out
the in-game activities
but these include limited time crisis
events where game-changing perimeters
are added as well as introducing new
enemies
weekly assignments that will offer
gameplay modifiers like veteran mode
which removes the hud gives you limited
ammo and enables friendly fire
and the maelstrom protocol where you are
challenged to run through nine sub-zones
each increasing in difficulty
this activity is ranked top schools will
earn react credits and unique headgear
all in all i went from being skeptical
to addicted within only a few hours
i do have concerns about the
replayability once i've levelled up my
favorite operators and have reached the
level 30 milestone
from what i've seen of the in-game so
far it doesn't really seem that
compelling to me but as i said i haven't
played it yet so hopefully i'm proven
wrong
this has been one of the most enjoyable
true tactical pve shooters that have
played in a long time
if you're interested in this style of
game i definitely recommend it
but in its current state you'll have a
better time playing with a couple of
friends
it just doesn't really feel like it's
been completely optimized for solo play
yet
fortunately they've included the buddy
pass system where you can invite two
people to play for free for up to two
weeks and there is cross play so it
makes it a little easier to bring
friends on board
anyway hopefully you found this useful
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]